klassisch fortsetzung
[Musik]
gerade unter haupt vom wald im roslin
schaffte heimat für die er wohne immer
zone siebte vom leben kennen darf ist
lindenstraße 10
sie hat schon immer die anarchie gegen
200 lindenstraße und krieg trifft mir
die ganze welt wenn man genauer geht die
beiden doktoren barbieri und ruhe die
leute einfach sportback macht von der
straße und vor ihren ganz
unterschiedlichen bewohnerinnen und
bewohnern oder auf eigenen ruhm mit den
anderen schlagen morgen zurück auf die
niedrigste moment ist ein film
das ist die lindenstraße ausgangs der
stadt luzern an dieser unscheinbaren
straße im reusstal in der gemeinde
littau leben menschen aus 22 nationen
hier ist die welt ein dorf und das drama
das sich im kleinen abspielt ist auch
ein globales fremde erobern neues
territorium die einheimischen
verteidigen ihre identität
dazu zählen eben dass ich short
die sind einfach ist diese hilfe so blöd
sie wie heute dann ja das runde am tisch
dank durchdachter der schlegel berühre
das funktioniert alles kommt alles ins
prozent russland
ja ja die kleine linken straße ist in
den schatten das thema etwas gedrängt
keine privilegierte wohnlage aber
günstige mietpreise nur die mieter sind
nicht immer so wie sich frau aus warten
an der lindenstraße 46 wünschte wieder
gibt es ärger diesmal mit dem sturen der
nachbarn
seit 34 jahren wohnt mit ihrem mann
bobby an der lindenstraße nummer 46
und so lange schon sorgt sie für ordnung
im haus und anstand im quartier
es ist frühling und allerlei blumen und
pflänzchen sprießen im kindergarten von
helen macht übrigens die einzige
schweizerin in der bunten stube auch die
liebe sprießt an der lindenstraße und
vielleicht gibt es nirgendwo sonst so
schöne und so schwierige
liebesgeschichten wie hier wo die ganze
welt zusammen trifft und wohin die
holländische krankenschwester verliebt
ist in ihre nigerianischen mann sam und
das gemeinsame kind
in nigeria gibt es lagos zehn millionen
menschen
es ist ein wenig wie die lindenstraße in
dieser straße hier gibt es ebenfalls
restaurants bordelle
die menschen sitzen draußen wenn es heiß
ist trinken lachen
mich erinnert das anna loos
im restaurant gartenhaus einem der zwei
wirtshäuser an der lindenstraße geht es
hoch zu und her
die gäste von training und brigitte
keller kommen von weit her
ausländer sind selten dabei das
restaurant gartenhaus ist ein
rückzugsgebiet der schweizer der
umgangston hier ländliche raum und die
musik mit vorliebe musik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind die kleinen und großen
geschichten der linken straße
die kinder spielen wieder fußball wo sie
nicht sollten
v kubica macht ihren laden auf
[Musik]
und alle geschichten ob sie böse enden
oder gut finden zuverlässig ihren weg in
den korb ersonnen von carmen denn carmen
kennt alle carmen ist die gute seele des
quartiers nach der lehre hatte ihr vater
gleichsam als überraschung für sie
dieses lokal gemietet
ich bitte euch ja das ist die
lindenstraße nummer 25
das haus das die fensterläden stets
geschlossen hat um nicht die quartier
richterin zu erzürnen frau die
osteuropäerinnen bieten hier ihre
dienste an
auch sie gehören zu karmans kundinnen
dass die verarbeitung g20 muss bestehen
sehen sie nachsehen
die einfach hier ist natürlich
interessante frage natürlich was seit 14
jahren arbeitet kamen jetzt schon an der
lindenstraße und in dieser zeit ist die
kurve salon zur nachrichtenbörse des
quartiers geworden
carmen weiss einfach alles etwa aus dem
guten ali wieder passiert ist gerade
jetzt heute morgen man glaubt es kaum
alisa die roma aus kosovo ist hausrat in
der nummer 34 und heute morgen trifft er
hinter seinem haus auf ein halbes
bettgestell und die zerbrochenen scheibe
seines autos das bett flog aus dem
fenster eines schweizer nachbarn
ich lebe mit dir leute aber für kein
problem meistens für was
nicolas linder straßentiere menschen v8
ja und jetzt immer wieder dazu lagen wie
es mit den menschen weiter gegangen ist
und ob es das noch gibt was ist
nachrichtenbörse tauchen ins herz von
der lindenstraße statt waffen
hineinreichen da jetzt gelegenheit
bekamen ihren platz für salons wie eh
und je aber hinter den kulissen rumort
ein investor hat kauft es ist wohl schon
die halbe lindenstraße gehört außer
strandbad uhus ist ihm da setzen wir
jetzt neuerdings auf 1 auf ihren opa
nicht kundschaft und nehmen auf der
stammtisch wie erlebt chris kaman wandel
also dich gibt es noch das immer schon
mal seit 22 jahren ist gar mit ihnen
jetzt shoretel in der straße am horn
schmiede und nicht wenige vor ihren
kunden sind ihre ideen ganze zeit treu
bleibe was ich hoffe in der lindenstraße
die letzte arbeit verändert also family
bemüht sind werkzeug elektronik renter
wohne immer da sind ja ach so du eine
mit dem gartenhaus highlights jahr
beziehung geschafft es ist also da ist
der ganztag da heißt der name ist die
stadt der hauptstadt stieg sie und das
ist schade sagt das für mich ist es teil
der häuser kaufte sie ist das wären
entwickelt alles in allem was ich sage
mir diese maschine kaputt machen
eigentlich so wird sehr großer star
endlich außerdem dass die immobilie
kauft und umbaut und handys und
andere branchen nachrichten austragung
das urteil hätte gekauft und jetzt geht
es um ein oder zwei größere ist mit -
krebs weil sie leider auch nicht wie es
weitergeht übrig geblieben und habe ich
muss gott hat so jetzt kann ihnen gar
nicht gewiss
das klingt us-autobauer platz
ich sage es mal so ich weiß nicht mal
angehört und bin ich an das sind gute
neuigkeiten für den gaumen noch mit
sport oder namen zu ihrer zurück
freiheit nur dahin wo die lindenstraße
hat sich bei ihren zum hirschen liedern
angemeldet gern würde jetzt gelungen was
läuft und gold im restaurant gartenhaus
aber es ist nur zur zeit nur noch am
mittag und am abend offen alles ist
renoviert der schaum vom alten europa
leitet
da ist einiges gange ganz anders die
schweiz und ihre menschen hängen alte
film also passiert wenn das hoch
siegbert sage ich glaube du wieder so
viele zukünftigen ex-frau das ist das
restaurant gartenhaus an der
lindenstraße und hier verteidigen die
einheimischen ihre volkskultur
[Musik]
zwei schwestern führen das gartenhaus
brigitte und vreni keller brigitte
wollte schon immer gerne geritten ging
aber nicht gerne zur schule schließlich
um ihrer schwester den traum zu erfüllen
hat vreni die wirte prüfung gemacht
[Musik]
sie macht
und da sind doch immer wieder schwierige
kunden zu bedienen
ich glaube ich
mit rosenheim und traunstein
doch du mensch wird es anders aus dem
wasser mit sättigen
darum geht's jetzt erneuert und heiße
tänze
[Musik]
witten
der stau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
das grafisch kamen vermutlich gemeint wo
sie vom stadttheater kredit hat aber wo
sind die jetzt vom stammtisch vor sie
nutze diese motoren und kunden heimat im
re strand auf der anderen straßenseite
treffen ruft bekannte gesichter bestand
ist da ich aber morgen gut sitzt die
alte heimat im neues recht machte
gartens fühlt sich der stammtisch römer
wohl nicht mal ein rauchverbot und tel
wirtin brigitte kögl tante sich weg von
der lindenstraße und auch weg von luzern
erfahre vor dem namen am stammtisch
sieht es bei minute wird sich linie
broker stufe 12 man dürfe die schoko
besucher zu bringen auch wenn sie nicht
gerne auf gartenhaus zurückdenke sie
vermisst
immerhin hat die trainer dann komm
laterne mit menschen zu tun und ihre
schwester vreni wo eigentlich anderen
autobahnraststätte schaufel groß helfen
so schnell wie jene beiden muss fühlt
sich ständig beschäftigen da ein
einziger hauptsitzung schnell zu machen
muss man schnell sieht über vier jahr
den schwester heiler und immer wird aber
ein teil vom alter leben hat es trotzdem
mit nun aber das ist dass ein standort
30 uhr gedauert jetzt etwas wirklich
empfehlen wo weitere nichts sie sind vom
vom garten aus weil sie höhen der
zivilität und jeder zweite hat
winterstraße skater muss ich immer die
gleiche
eine stunde betragen
ja was ist denn das für eine geschichte
sind dass ihr überhaupt weit gegangen
sind vom garten von der linzer straße
ist also sinnvoll kauft heute das leben
genommen
wo sind da die demnach und böse und so
ist noch irgendeine treffen gestellt wir
haben also viel ich weiß allein gegangen
aber ich bin krank wurde und der einzig
sein also dieses neues konzept und die
also so schnell dieses kann also als
sicher kündigung kommt ja es ist so
stellt drei wochen sind mit brauner dann
sind sie nochmals sehen ja dahinter
straße
das macht irgendwie mit dem zittern ist
so lange aufgehoben
wenn ich eine frage ist natürlich
unangenehm aber es ist so klar und ruhig
ja aber klar physischen oder ich danke
sie ich sehe da haben sie auch beim
ochsen sich seit sie sich hat schon ins
fliegen für das wohl und die zukunft und
das dauert bis kommt dass er das immer
zuversichtlich alles gute
berlin der straße es ist jetzt mit oxid
langsam wird das gartenhaus stoffe
[Musik]
die trojaner auf das rechte rand unter
der neuen führung
sowieso sind geschäft ordentlich konzept
vom guard russ es geht nur mein heiß
mini wer schafft die hoch wie sorgfältig
hat allende straße hat mir wirklich die
ganze welt was ist der große traum mit
dem gottes ich eigentlich dass er sich
und wir hier gesamtkonzeption
lindenstraße wichtige wenn mich eine
suite womit der straße schrieb novität
dass das der blogs wird wo es um viel
aber sie sagen hey das ist ein guter ort
um den jahren musik verbringen
gesamtkonzeption lindenstraße h was das
ich muss ist der eigentümer vom
gartenhaus erklären
im kartenraum musik kunst galerien uns
ein open air bar an der lindenstraße
gehört alles mit der zahl 13
ein griechisches flair für all die
sachen beim aufpolieren
das auto passt also ist bild
das gab der chef persönlich sehr breit
oder der uni breitschmid ist ein
erfolgreicher geschäftsmann in kürze
firma wo zahnbürste und dental produkt
herstellt jetzt investiert das ist
vermögen baugebiet und immobilie wieder
oder linde stoffs breitschmid schön dass
sie gar schnell wie ich aus irgendwelche
gedanken inzwischen schon die ganze
minder stolz dass wir viele betriebe
aber das gehört jetzt da alles
ich würde sagen betrifft ihre laune ist
natürlich weiß ich dass ich schon so und
damals damals vorstellungskraft dass ich
irgendwie vom 15 kempis werden
das gab mir gesehen mit diesen inhalten
machen und einfach nicht nur gute
stimmung sie sehen die relativ lang trug
sich schon gefühlt hat aber wo mir den
gesehen wenn die straße anders
entwickeln ist das natürlich der drei
punkte wenn man das kippen wenn man
handys an das publikum welcher die
straße bringen
jetzt kann man sagen sie schaut musste
sich um die die multikulti viertel oder
ein gewaltiger stress also dass das was
ich mache ich renoviere andere da werdet
viele überfahren und platz kein gewertet
reprise stieg natürlich auch ihren platz
findet die hände sauber der lindenstraße
keinem das ist die andere sieht diesen
weg ganz konkret von meiner tochter
kritisiert der will es jeder bekennt und
die lampen eine gewalttat petershausen
ich mache mir leid weil ich mich
wirklich immer so schlechte zustand sie
das gemüse sanieren oder sich es nicht
dass sie das luxussanierung roma sei
zwar nötig sondern es ist wirklich zu
stand sie vor schluss noch nicht
diskutieren gibt das mit dem
waffengeschäft vergangen ineichen daher
gehört ziemlich alles weg nach so langer
zeit der lindenstraße die stadt stand
also mir in der werden sie dem user
stimmen sind sowieso stufe sieben ein
also das ist ein event ist oder ob dabei
sich nämlich jetzt also das lokal oder
umbauen und macht hände ganz anders tag
rund um das mindeste was man dazu erst
man das für sie auch noch die besten
nutzt insgesamt passieren durch sehr
schlecht genutzten jetzt herrscht auch
das hängt sicher vorstellig was ist ein
in der straße also wie seelische stars
so der muss ganz neues machen
bis linda straße im monopoly fix ist
dass kurze studiert also ich habe früher
das gegenteil ein monopoly gespielt so
langweilig grunde haben wir einen grund
weniger quote machen sagt gründer und
früherer unfertig von der lindenstraße
gibt es bei die sitte
in die obere stück vom gartenhaus
formiert hat der uli braun schmid frisch
renovierte vier zimmer wohnungen für
stolze zweite musik 500 franken pro
monat die erste mini jobs über ein breit
schmidts größte [ __ ] stuttgarter
lindenstraße ist der us blog gab anfangs
vom quartier komplett erneuert
als weniger für lütow temporären
unterkunft buchen ab 200 franken pro
woche für das wg-zimmer von früh an und
alle müssen user frau in dem haus
gewohnt im ersten stock sich als paar
jahre vorher von der lindenstraße weg
zucker dem balkon ist und nicht alles
was ich vor angst zurück war aber vor
standhaft bleiben und hat für rechten
damit sorgen wir machen noch einmal 30
jahre 2007 in der nummer 36 verteidigt
frau die mutter helvetia der
lindenstraße die hausordnung und das
territorium ihrer parkplätze und wer
weiß auch ihre idee davon was die
schweiz ist und wie sie sein sollte
kultur sind wir aber nur wenn sie
deutlich intensiver ja passen nur
befindet sich frau an talenten straße
schon längst in der minderheit und immer
mehr ausländer kommen von überall her
den frieden von vw störten überdies auch
schon afrikanische asylbewerber die
wohnten drüben in nummer 27 und 29
aber nicht da wo er sein auto abstellt
platz
platz und das hätte glaubt way home
school vorhaben hatte
bis morgen hast du deine berufene tricks
die den beruf
was man noch probleme habt ihr euch mit
eurer riet den karton wird es noch etwas
komisch all dieser familie 20 über sehen
jetzt dass japaner und die hand so viel
war so viel war bei der kartensammlung
papiere kaufen alles mögliche und
jupiter und ihrer alles genau will ich
sie haben für den adresse ist familie
zwanziger der blutzucker alles bin jene
20 meter raum dann erkläre
[Musik]
jetzt eine ganz heißes wasser floss und
hat aus abu rheine mit dem rest ja das
ist nötig sie ja wird es schlimm wenn
die da so hat wenn deine seite
es geht in andere orte sehen ist auch
recht aber nicht immer wieder aus wenn
die hauswand werde so wirst
naja aber so wenig zu bieten
ich bin besser geschützt
[Musik]
zurück in die gegenwart zurück und klar
für seinen gaumen wie abgemacht treffen
dort an ihre wieder acht jahren noch
empfehlen die ressource zeit nur wenn
wir sagen dass ich jetzt für jan immel
dieses oder gutes ja ja ja ja da kann
ich der grandios gang läuft jetzt fehlen
darf ich bin jemand der lindenstraße
sind und ich muss mit dem auto gar nicht
am erfolg warum wie die hauptstadt
passierte so viel wie lange sind sie
aber lindenstraße sind also wie sie 20
jahre ganz sicher nicht ab werk machte
vor
ich bin wirklich gehen denn du nix aber
plötzlich auf dass jemand kommt
warum ich sind immer gegangen die mir
dass ich große private gründe bin ich
will von dem partner konnte ich wieder
meine bitterste ja ja ja das ist die
lindenstraße zum rechten sehen immer
sind ja dann bin ich ja noch frieden
übergeben
ich frage frau y schnell mit mir zu
ihrem alte wohnhaus für und data ich
einige vom tour
tja ich begegne flasche sind jetzt bin
ich was mache 20 maschinen und so alles
an
ja das ist nicht schön er hat deshalb
vorher ganz am schluss zu und daran
natürlich schön gearbeitete nehmen ja
aber das macht sie zerstöre glaube ich
dass wir mit frau am fenster ist die
nachfolgerin
man solle doch am besten gerade zeit
voraus die auch honig oder frau ist
gerade für eine temporäre mir tops setzt
darum leute zu ihm und seiner bitte
liebe kampf oder meter hoch
das buch nicht nur männer lief ins
gespräch
bei der anprobe tatsächlich wir haben
den schwung kam ja aus wenn doch damit
ist nun aber es ist schlecht so
gesprungen ist noch nicht gut aus das
hat mir ja mehr oder weniger die
mitfahrer und die klingt das jetzt ganz
nah oder sie hier
personen mit einer decke
das wieder ganz so fix wie schaut das
gab durchlebt uhr für sie da
naja jetzt mag ich nicht und jetzt
voreilig offiziell als strafe dafür da
vor schluss hatte stellten die heim- als
auch wünsche ihnen alles gute und danken
und mit ihren ausstieg schweizer skater
hegglin honig ist ja es hat sich vieles
verändert an der lindenstraße ventures
in wegzogen hus ausgebaut wurde werden
die einzig trend aber eine verhältnis
der ali said the estate of autokratisch
alice die roma aus kosovo seit 15 jahren
an der lindenstraße hausmeister der
nummer 34 putzt die unterrichtsräume des
gutenberg schulhauses in luzern ali kam
1993 als kriegsflüchtling in die schweiz
zwei seiner kinder kamen hier zur welt
2002 bekamen den bescheid er müsse das
land wieder verlassen
die mitschüler seiner kinder sammelten
unterschriften für die familie legte
rekurs ein
noch zweifelt die asyl kommission in
bern
ob sie es den in ihrer heimat verfolgten
roma zumuten kann
nach kosovo zurückzukehren gab auch
schon sind alles nicht alles doppelt
stunde
und eine 2 kind da wir wollen schweiz
der saudische 22 kindergarten trauer
wird dich selber arbeitet heißt nicht
viel auf das und die hoffen können die
blieben schweiz integriert die gleichen
wie eine schweizer vorstand kinder weder
der schweizer durch mit kinder sollen
spezialisten frau gewaltsam erledigter
arbeit leben schafft
[Musik]
ali und seine familie hoffen jetzt dass
sich die gnadenfrist einer
provisorischen aufenthaltsbewilligung
solange erstreckt bis es nicht mehr
möglich ist die kinder ihrer neuen
heimat zu entwurzeln seine alte heimat
aber hat er nicht vergessen und wann
immer es geht um hochzeiten und festen
spielt ali die musik der roma als
probelokal gibt eine alte baracke hinter
dem haus an der lindenstraße
[Musik]
ein lied hat ali selbst geschrieben
es handelt von einem 20-jährigen roma
der ohne familie in die schweiz kommt
und sich allein im neuen land und schnee
und kälte zurechtfinden muss
da war doch noch was die kaputte
heckscheibe des autos das halbe bett
gestellt dass aus einem fenster flog hat
jemand den schaden bezahlt das ist die
abfahrts philosophie von alexei die roma
aus dem kosovo vater von vier kindern
provisorische aufenthaltsbewilligung
[Musik]
der alice die acht jahre später
wiederzufinden ist einfach ich muss
einfach die musik noch
[Musik]
das immer richtig er seitdem nehmen oder
20 jahren bin ich täglich familie wie
gut die top danke von kurdisch alles gut
222 tochter er hatte die sonne schüsse
teilt ich bin mir immer die jungs also
das heißt in dem film handy ja noch
nicht wissen wir sind in der schweiz
blieben
ich merke wie sehr ich sie also jetzt
ein der muss ich sage danke zu mir
kommen die schweizer post ist schwierig
sie die bürger nicht so viel ich danke
von berg probleme also zum sprache bin
ich nicht so ganz gut aber gute kinder
bis zur lösung immer noch immer leer
und da sind sie jetzt dort der einzige
schweizer der lindenstraße
dieser auf
also ich
weltweit sind genau ich glaube in
solothurn abgegangen war sie das denken
weil sie bin die sich schade aber ich
sehe menschen abschnitt hause der
bislang größer als es die musik machen
das ist mein hobby das ist schön
darf man das auch kein problem
[Musik]
der ali saidi trotzdem schweizer kraft
musik der verbündeten immer noch mit
seiner ursprünglichen heimat
[Musik]
lindenstraße luzern der steht nicht
still
es ist zwar immer noch ein
multikulturelles stress mit dem einer
höheren ausländeranteil aber
gleichzeitig wird er saniert und
renoviert lindenstraße wirklich einmal
zu einer trendigen ausgangs meile wird
das allerdings steht noch in den sternen
letzte woche lag am ried welt oder
artisten 2008 haben einen film zeigen
was es für das programm von circus knie
alles braucht sie zehnte franco und der
fredy knie
die klare chefin sie im zirkus jetzt
starte generationenwechsel aladin und
der franke junior übernehmen und msc und
war sie schon pläne für die chris wurde
wofür sie pro jahr zum ersten mal auf
tennis zirkus knie
fortsetzung folgt innere buche